so the US is getting absolutely boned on
evangelion's Blu-ray release the final
rebuild is finally making it to home
release with a tasty 4K Blu-ray but this
bad boy is currently priced at 67 which
is expensive enough for what it is but
then you look at the UK's release which
gets all the same things but in an
awesome steel book and only 50 pounds
which is about 63 dollars that's some
right like the craziest part is
that the US released was 80 originally
and only dropped in price once the UK
one was put on sale and blew them away
at least 4K Blu-rays are region free but
the shipping cost would probably make it
more expensive overall honestly it's a
frustrating situation all around for us
Ava fans